Mike how are you this morning buddy how
are you good you know play oh that Miss
oh no no I I didn't know if you had more
to expound upon an upgrade yeah we're
heading to New York a day early this
weekend my son and my wife coming with
me we're gonna have a good time let's
see it's it's a great day you got an
update you got an update a loop weekly
nothing yet they put him in the
concussion evaluation process last night
which surprised a lot of people it's
felt like just watching it on TV and of
course we don't speculate on injuries
but you have thoughts go through your
head that there was some sort of dire
diagnosis that have been given to him in
the moment possibly some sort of a leg
injury torn Achilles whatever that
caused him to react the way he did he
was reacting with a sense of finality
that his season's over and that's what
confused a lot of people when we heard
that it was a concussion but he went
through a concussion last year he missed
several games you know we don't know
papa privately with these guys go
through when they're dealing with a
concussion you have headaches have light
sensitivity have concerns you have fears
and um you know he he presumably does
not want to go through again what kept
him out of action for nearly a month in
2015 yeah I didn't know if people talked
about his knee at all because it was
bent awkwardly and I I don't know if you
know in the moment like there's
something really severe with a
concussion as you do a knee injury the
shortness of breath so I thought it was
more of those than it was the concussion
that had him so emotional yeah i mean
that's that's what i thought that they
were gonna have to lift him up that's
what's surprising when he stood up and
got on the cart that we'll wait a minute
i thought he had a broken leg or
something where the doctors came out and
said hey look buddy you're done um you
know we're gonna you gotta you have
whatever injury it is that is going to
keep you out for the rest of the year
that was how i interpreted the the
reaction but uh you know he's been there
with that concussion and when you love
the sport you love your teammates you
want to be available and you go into
this great unknown of when you're gonna
get cleared to play again and you're
gonna be missing games while this team
is trying to turn things around and get
back into the playoff chase it is it's
you know it's a tough moment for a guy
who clearly has given a lot of him
self to his profession how'd you get
involved in the Aaron Rodgers discussion
here the back and forth is going on well
look here's what happened and after they
lost to the colts he came out and said
that they didn't have any energy on the
sidelines and then after they lost to
the titans he came out and said they
need to have a healthy fear that if you
don't do your job you're going to get
you're going to get cut and in both
instances the head coach of the football
team is the guy ultimately responsible
whether it's ensuring that there's
energy on the sidelines during a game
whether it's instilling the fear in the
players that if they don't do their jobs
are not going to have those jobs and I
just felt like there was a
passive-aggressive thing going on with
Aaron Rodgers is a smart guy who knows
what he says and understands the
implications when he says these things
publicly out of press conference after a
loss I just read that and I interpret
that as there's a problem between him
and his head coach and you know whatever
he said it prompted Mike McCarthy to
pull the Stuart Smalley routine on
Monday where he says I'm a highly
successful NFL coach whoever says that
but regardless how successful you are
you don't come out and say that and it
just led me to believe that there's real
tension between these guys and that's
what prompted someone it is Locker to
ask him about it and he said the
criticism of McCarthy is ridiculous I
wish somebody would have followed up by
saying well but Aaron who were you
criticizing when you said that there was
an energy on the sidelines and who are
you criticizing when you're saying that
there isn't a healthy fear that guys are
going to lose their jobs that they don't
do their job so I think there's more to
this and I tend to think I struck a
nerve and a like I bet you know when you
do this as long as we have then you get
called out a lot I really don't care
about it anymore as long as they get my
name right and he did whether they're
you know I'm fine with it I because I
don't think I did anything that it is
quote/unquote wrong I think it's an
accurate read on the situation and you
know if if it's not then why is he
saying these things publicly so you're
you're okay with any publicity is good
publicity even if Aaron Rodgers is
critical of you or your website
absolutely absolutely i absolutely yeah
any publicity is good publicity as long
as they get your name right absolutely
what we found limited exceptions but
this one I they played it on ESPN what
the hell were they thinking at ESPN I
thought that was great
it's not like people are going to
suddenly stopped coming to the website
if they think it's a bunch of crap to
come check it out and see if it is crap
and if it is I'll stand on my crap I I
take pride in my crap and I I tend to
think that far more often than not we
have an accurate read on what's happened
at the NFL level and you know sometimes
people don't like it I think that's what
this comes down to I've been reading the
jet perlman book about Brett Favre and
you know it's a different mindset in
green bay and the media isn't as
aggressive as say it would be in New
York and I think Aaron Rodgers had been
spoiled by that over the years and then
they're probably been things he said at
times that he would have been criticized
heavily for in other markets and he
doesn't like you know we know he's
sensitive he's so sensitive be sensitive
about being sensitive remember that 60
minutes profile they did and he
complained because it portrayed him is
sensitive and they issued a statement
saying see he's proving our point he is
sensitive so it doesn't surprise me that
it landed on his radar screen it doesn't
surprise me he reacted and I mean I
still gotta do what I think's right and
i gotta say what i think is right we're
trying to service the audience and uh if
somebody calls me out for it and I just
did you just call it a roll off your
back and you keep moving thank you
Michael see you on Sunday have a great
weekend all rights anybody that's Mike
Florio ProFootballTalk the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience